so the first time everyone here worked
together was the first book club so
Candace um but you and Jane have known
each other for a while right hundreds of
years since
I was 17. yeah I was my boyfriend had a
crush on her thank you very much and
she's not home yes she knew where she
lived and so he took me to her house and
we rang the doorbell and and somebody
opened it and she at 17 was on the top
of a ladder and I just remember looking
up and thinking
I never want to be around her again this
is the most beautiful human being I have
ever seen in my life and plus she's
brilliant and she's written many books
speaking of books so we go back we go
back I love I love that kind of
friendship and then you get to work
together that's cool yeah yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
oh
[Music]